the i-team's vanessa murphy says how
police
say the alleged crime unfolded she has
that story now we do want to warn you
that the details in this report are
disturbing
this is five-year-old ryan james peralta
his father sent this video and these
photos to the i-team
an arrest report describes some of the
final moments of the boy's life
22-year-old lauren courtney faces
charges for first degree murder
and child abuse according to this report
courtney told police she babysat for
ryan and his seven-year-old sister since
august ryan's father had installed
cameras in his home
after his daughter said courtney hurt
ryan while at work he received a call
from courtney that ryan wasn't doing
well and he was coughing up blood
ryan's dad returned home to find his son
unresponsive
on the couch those cameras a key piece
of evidence
detectives called the footage horrendous
and say courtney is seen dragging ryan
while he was limp
kicking him in the head dropping him so
his head hit the bathroom floor
punching him in the face and dragging
him into the shower
the report states she turns the water on
as ryan
cries and moans in pain once his dad
comes home
courtney leaves her boyfriend telling
police she even picked up mcdonald's on
the way home
police say when they interviewed
courtney and told her ryan might not
survive
she expressed no emotion the report says
the beating left the previously healthy
boy
neurologically devastated with internal
injuries the next day
ryan died courtney is here at the clark
county detention center her next court
date is set for may
on tuesday we first reported on two go
fund me accounts for ryan's family
viewers have been reaching out helping
those funds
to just about reach their goals vanessa
murphy
8 news now